scrolling social media it can actually
be quite stimulating you get a lot of
dope I mean oh there's this oh there's
that but very quickly you're no longer
getting the novelty but you're
continuing to do it you almost don't
know why you're doing it at that point
it shifts over to something that's a bit
more like an obsessive compulsive
Behavior but the acting out of the
compulsion merely serves to increase the
obsession there's no Anxiety Relief by
carrying out the compulsion the dopamine
quickly wanes and then you find that
you're scrolling like why am I doing
this this isn't that interesting we have
to learn to self-regulate the amount of
time think about it in terms of the
positive the more time away from
something the more positively
reinforcing it will be when you return